sit without further ado I first invited
the President of the European Council
donuts asked to take the floor Thank You
bourbon with the president dear friends
tonight the European Council decided to
grant the United Kingdom a flexible
extension of the article 50 period until
the 31st of October
this means an additional six months for
the UK during this time the cause of
action will be entirely in the UK's
hands it can still ratify their
withdrawal agreement in which case the
extension will be terminated it can also
reconsider the whole bracket strategy
that might lead to changes in the
political declaration but not in the
withdrawal agreement until the end of
this period the UK will also have the
possibility to revoke article 50 and
counsel brings it all together
the UK will continue sincere cooperation
as a full member state with all its
rights and as a close friend and trusted
ally in the future let me finish with a
message to our British friends this
extension is as flexible as I expected
and a little bit shorter than I expected
but it's still enough to find the best
possible solution please do not waste
this time thank you thank you and now
president Juncker of the European
Commission oui Bonjour
good morning Donald morning ladies and
gentlemen
we had a meeting which was sometimes
difficult but always led by her wish to
reach agreement amongst the 27 and with
the United Kingdom now from an
institutional point of view I would
simply like to say that the Commission
is entirely satisfied with the outcome
we have agreed that there may be
occasions where the 27 will need to meet
as 27 without our British friends in
order to discuss the future developments
now some people have said that we're
trying to introduce different types of
status between different countries in
the EU including between countries
leaving and countries remaining but
there's a precedent of course for
dealing with different countries in a
different way when I was president of
the European Council in December 1997 I
proposed to my colleagues that the
Eurogroup be set up there was great
reluctance the UK Denmark Sweden and
others but we did this because we felt
that those who needed to manage the
single currency together should be able
to speak amongst themselves while
obviously ensuring proper continuity
with the work of the Council of
Ministers the ministers of finance at
the time that's basically what we've
done today we have recalled to our
British colleagues that there should be
the principle of sincere cooperation
between all Member States and we are
convinced that the United Kingdom will
respect its obligations in June when we
meet again we will not be renegotiating
amongst ourselves or with the UK the
agreement that was reached months ago
because the withdrawal agreement must be
respected in its entirety
well we don't want the withdrawal
agreement to be called into question
because that would jeopardize the
backstop agreement that we have
negotiated with our Irish friends and
I'm sure Irish friends comforted to see
that their wishes and concerns have been
taken into account by their friends in
the European Union so there will
probably be a European election in the
United Kingdom that may seem a bit old
but rules are rules and we must respect
European law and then we will see what
happens
I do rather regret the fact that we only
talk about brexit I read the British
European press this morning brexit
brexit brexit but president tusk and I
reached an agreement that no one
expected with China and yet there was
hardly anything about that in the
international press well the swath of
course gave a detailed report I mean
they did it's true
after all the soir reports well on
things the noise outside which of course
is from outside the European Union the
swab did reports on what I consider to
be a historic agreement but what it
proves is that we are over focused on
matters relating to brexit and
insufficiently focused on other matters
that we work on so yes I'm very happy
that an agreement has been reached at
amongst the 27 I think it was essential
to demonstrate that the 27 stands United
in their analysis and in the action and
in October we'll see what happens along
you know a meeting with too long a
meeting
thank you and the floor is now open for
your questions and I think the first
question goes through Chris yes the
gentleman - all right Thank You
bourbonnais Chris Morris from BBC
president us you said the extension was
a little shorter than you expected isn't
it from your perspective in some ways
the worst of both worlds not short
enough to really put on the pressure in
the UK Parliament to get a deal passed
quickly but not long enough to allow you
to set aside brexit to focus on other
things for any useful period of time and
secondly as you know article 50 says
nothing or doesn't rule out multiple
extensions is there anything in the
language agreed today which says October
the 31st is the final deadline or is it
possible that come mid-october late
October we will once again be having a
summit like this and working out how
much longer we're going to extend again
I think it's always better to have a
piece of something than I love nothing
and which means that in six months more
than six six months and almost three
weeks it's it could be enough for good
solution if this goodwill and and
majority for some solutions in but in
London of cousin in the House of Commons
[Music]
general I'm satisfied because it's if
you know not only the today's discussion
but also our preparations showed that
the the this idea of flexible extension
was not so obvious for some our partners
and this is why I think we have to be
maybe not happy but satisfied by this by
the solution our intention is to
finalize the whole process in October
but mmm and the political intention was
clear among the member states that our
our wish and our hope is that the UK
will be ready with with the final
solution until the end of October but
I'm too old to exclude mmm another
scenario we said I think it's still
everything is possible it's mmm and the
second question was before the deal
would be total disaster everyone knows
that so we have to do everything to
avoid a heart ill that's what Donald I
myself are trying to do till now we have
been quite successful
I like the decision we have taken to not
tonight because the ante has been fixed
on the 31 of
October I have to leave my job on the
1st of November this year so my guess
would be that we will have no tonight
session because if we had I have to
leave the meeting at midnight thank you
and I think just the gentleman to our
left was next Jim thank you good morning
Jim Bronstein from the Financial Times
if October is is now the deadline and if
as as you've said president asked the
the course of affairs is now fully in
the UK's hands between now and then what
is the point of this review that's been
discussed for June what why are we
having this and what can take place on
that occasion if everything is now in
London sense it must be clear this
assessment or reviewing journeys only to
update us on the progress when it comes
to ratification process and and the
legal process is in in the UK this June
is not for for for decisions about
extension or and my intention is not
even not to discuss but only to inform
the member states about the current
situation it's
in June we are taking stock of what has
happened from now to them it's not a
negotiation session it's not another
cliff as we would insert in the normal
program as far as our programs are
normal they are not that we don't have
the intention to negotiate in June the
real moment the moment of the vital
moment the decision is October in June
we are tech stock preparing the meeting
will have little in October
June is not a cliff edge moment for for
to take new decisions that it must be
clear thank you and we'll take one last
question yes the gentleman in the middle
Nicholas from Bloomberg News can I ask
you to elaborate on paragraphs 7 & 8 of
today's decision what do you expect from
the UK what do you mean by Serco
cooperation do you expect the UK to not
participate for examining the votes for
high-level appointments in June what
exactly is it that you expect and the
second question if I may
given the differences today over the
length of extension do you insist that
the unity of the 2007 still holds or did
France go rogue today
Cynthia cooperation in Cynthia
cooperation and we have only good two
experiences with the resumes government
when it comes to the lolly loyalty to
our rules and principles Ian in Brussels
and there's no any kind of intention to
establish a new format for four member
state and the article 50 and of course
the United Kingdom is and will remain
during the whole process a firm member
of the European Union no doubt with all
the obligations but also with all the
rights and especially with voting right
no no doubts but our intention was to
have some you know political guarantees
and decorations that the UK will not use
any any kind of political blocking so
tricks and to be destructive or to stop
our work or to use this possibility as a
political instrument to impulse
something and I think well III
trust what Teresa may declare today and
I have no doubt that that this this term
sincere cooperation is treated seriously
the reference to sincere cooperation is
a reference to a basic principle of the
treaties which are governing our living
together and I trust which I made that
the United Kingdom will not step away
from the treaty obligation they have to
incorporate with the other member states
missus yeah loyal way I know that in
parts of Europe sometimes in Britain too
there is this idea that Witten could
block in the next coming years decisions
of the European Union we had heard
voices coming from wit and that the
Britain wants to be a very difficult
partner of the others that's nothing new
the other point is that we should did
dramatize this issue because the next
big decisions we have to take
appointment of the president of European
Council of the one of the European
Commission and others can be dealt with
with qualified majority even trade
treaties have to be dealt with and can
be dealt with and must be dealt with if
in essence we by qualified majority
voting so the possibilities for Britain
to block decisions are very very limited